is
going to talk about diversity and
inequality in information diffusion on
social networks
um
and for not leaving the talk to go get
cupcakes upstairs
but okay so let's get started this talk
is very related to some of the talks
we've seen today and it has a flavor of
thinking more about the communities that
are involved in information diffusion so
I've done this work at Columbia where I
was a PhD student with my advisor
Augustine chantro and one of our
collaborators uh Jesse shinihan who's
also now a PhD student
and uh for a brief introduction although
we've had we've seen a lot of that today
information that's propagated through a
social network has ramification in a
bunch of applications from the news that
we read Technologies we hear about we
know that the problem of information
diffusion as Muhammad pointed out
started from running marketing
promotions in an efficient way and it
has bigger ramifications than that such
as public health issues who gets access
to vaccine who hears about them and so
on
and depending on what application we're
using the setup of the problem may look
very differently in running marketing
promotions at least in in the current
ones we think more about having a small
and targeted campaign that reaches a
subset of the population for which we
think the information is relevant
whereas in a public health issue
um case we would think about the central
planner that's trying to distribute
information to as many people as
possible in a way that's efficient and
that requires much larger campaign
and this is the kind of applications
that we care about and and we're we want
to think about who are the people who
this information uh reaches and
um what groups are there part of
as a motivating example as as we spoke
about covid and access to vaccine
there's been a lot of research in
showing that there is a gap in
vaccination between more and less Vernal
vulnerable groups in the US
um particularly depending on different
counties but also correlated with race
and in particular Hispanics have one of
the lowest vaccination rate this is an
example from New Mexico from last year
um compared to the the general
population
and many people have thought well maybe
that's vaccine hesitancy but that's not
the entire explanation and other recent
surveys were showing that they are some
of the most willing groups to receive
coveted shots but it's about having
access to information about the cost and
access and having access to correct
information about it
um so so that's where the problem lies
on like how do we fix this Gap in
information access between groups in
this case when we may think about
demographic groups in these applications
we may think about different types of
groups in general
and Beyond the the the access to public
health uh guidelines and issues there
are a bunch of um other applications
like opportunities like Mohamed stock
talked about the division of
microfinancing loans between among
people in rural villages in India and
again like how do you make sure that you
diffuse information among these groups
and think about the network structure
that's particular to to to these groups
as opposed to more urban settings
um so with that in mind I want to get to
the how we Define this problem and how
we formalize it it's been formalized as
a very classic Problem by came back
leinberg toddrush in 2003 and we've seen
this formulation before for everyone who
hasn't seen it earlier this day
um the main idea is that you have a
network of people and you are trying to
diffuse you have a central planner who's
trying to get a piece of information to
as many people as possible and you can't
get it to people directly so what you do
is that you want to have a selection of
an early adopter set a set of people who
first receive this information and rely
on them to spread it to their friends
who spread it to their friends and so on
in a process that Cascades so how do you
select these people based on a
particular budget that may depend on
your constraints computational costs and
so on
um is the actual optimization problem
so if I hear might be the diffusion
function as is the selection of this
early adopter set and case your budget
and there are many models to think about
how you diffuse information in this case
we're thinking about the independent
Cascade where everyone diffuses
information with the probability P
independent of everyone else this is the
model that Muhammad using this talk
about information diffusion as well
so as we know this problem is then we
complete we can't solve it directly but
we have some approximation algorithms
that are able to think about it and to
uh approximate a good solution for the
selection of this seed set or early
adopters and those rely on centrality
we've seen algorithms that think about
degree people who are very popular
sometimes they do good sometimes they
don't do that well distance centrality
and eigenvector centrality and so on
another algorithm is that I think about
doing this in an iteratively way in an
iterative way like greedy which does
have theoretical guarantees for how
close it can get to the optimal solution
but it's very computationally expensive
and it's Muhammad mentioned it requires
full Network information which sometimes
is really hard to get
Beyond this what all of these also have
or don't have in common is that they're
agnostic to communities they don't take
directly into account
um different communities that may be
present in our Network like demographics
and so on and because of that people
have shown that a very recent work has
shown that if you don't take into
account Community affiliation
you might reproduce bias
which is present at the level of
centralities in the Outreach as well
which may mean that groups certain
groups particular minority groups may be
left out of the information Loop in the
Outreach and there's a gap in Access in
who gets this information that you're
trying to spread and here are pointering
blue and red which can represent
demographics gender interests groups
depending on the application that you
mostly care about
so this work showed this um modern
empirically and theoretically from 2019
and
um we were thinking at the same time uh
when we're publishing our work on like
how do you fix this problem and the way
this work from from benefits at all
um was thinking about it was to say well
I want to recover that Gap in
information access between the two
groups so I can impose a constraint in
my optimization function at the level of
the Outreach so I want the proportion of
people who have heard this information
who are from one group and the other
group to more be more or less the same
as my proportion of groups in general if
I have 30 percent of people who are red
I want 30 of people who have heard this
information to be read or to have this
red label
and they have shown that when you do
that well you might end up with this
fairness efficiency trade-off which is
prevalent in many problems when you
think about fairness in this particular
way and the way this trade-off looks
like is that if you don't impose any
constraint on your problem and you just
want to use some centrality Metric to
optimize for maximizing the Outreach
maybe you're going to reach a lot of
people but maybe one of the group is
going to be severely underrepresented
meaning that let's say if you have equal
numbers of red and blue here the red
group is just like way underrepresented
in the Outreach as well so they don't
hear the information as much as a blue
group
if you do impose this
um parity constraint at the level of the
Outreach maybe the information reaches
people in a more proportional way but
you're gonna reach fewer people in
general and that's what they show
and our work um came out kind of at the
same time with a slightly different
approach
is there a question yes
okay
so how bad can this be quoted for
example bees that
let's say I look at the optimal
fare
seating I get sort of
as you're an example two wet women and
two two red and two blue because it's 50
50. but now you do your optimal
what if in the optimal you suddenly get
three reps and 20 blue maybe then you
don't care because you say you actually
while you might not be as Fair as a
minority is better off if I do so
yeah so this might not be quite the
right
you see what I'm saying do I care about
fairness do I am I unhappy because my
neighbor switch or do I just want to get
as many red people rich as possible well
you you would I see your point I think
the actual battery that they use is to
say like if
um they use this together with another
one that says like what's if I have like
50 50 red and blue and if this in this
case I reach only
um
let's say like two out of 10 people who
are red
um but in this case
sorry let me find the right example for
that
I think the the idea would be that
you're measuring the proportion of
people who are red who have reached the
fraction of people who have heard this
information in both cases and you want
it to be more or less proportional so
you can have both definitions that one
and one that says in the case that you
mentioned actually reach more people in
general in Red so I have three as
opposed to two so I'm actually
increasing the rate at which I'm
reaching red people which makes in a
sense more fair but if I reach one red
person and nine blue people then I'm
less fair and that's the case that they
kind of observe so that's what I found
so they didn't find this strange
behavior that you could make the red
better off but it's less Fair yeah yeah
there I don't think they have found that
because in a lot of the cases they found
that you actually reach a smaller
proportion of the red community in
general as well
um and I think it might of course it
depends on the network but we'll discuss
some assumptions where that might hold
or that may not hold
so with that in mind our approach was to
think about how do you recover this gap
between information access between the
two groups in the following way think
about that we have partially known
networks in which we may be able to use
um centrality metrics such as degree
resistance centrality or local
information that we may have
and we're going to use a model of
network growth in trying to tap into the
inactive communities those have have
been left out in a way
um that that's trying to recover that
Lost Gap there and with that we're
actually able to prove that there are
theoretical conditions depending on the
network model and on the diffusion
process for when being more fair can
actually increase your efficiency
overall and the intuition is that well
you kind of left out the whole group of
the of the of the
um of your population out of the
information Loop when you just focus on
very central people and I know this idea
has been floated around earlier but this
is um this is what we're going to
discuss in detail today and what theory
can tell us about this problem
so uh it's very this problem was was
very much inspired by the talk that was
earlier today just a few seats more if
you saw it the main take away with that
you can do random seating with just a
few extra notes and you're gonna do like
so you're gonna do comparable and
sometimes better to Optimal seating so
in case in which you don't have Network
information you might as well be random
and if you're if you're able to have
some flexibility on the budget then
you're able to be pretty comparable to
how well an optimal sitting would do in
terms of the Outreach and then our
thoughts were well that would be great
to do so but what if we are able to
leverage that in a strategic way to make
sure that different communities reach
um they're being reached by the
information in a more fair way or more
diverse way
um
so the the main Vision was the device
that you see in this information Gap is
a sign of like inefficient seating
and in by tapping into these inactive
communities we're trying to do that in
the early adopter set rather than in the
outreaching earlier in the pipeline and
see where that leads us and seeing that
we can do that with the knowledge of a
network model and thinking about
different centrality metrics this is a
way to to to figure out what's the
effect on the Outreach and hopefully get
a better Outreach in particular
conditions
so
if we're thinking about awareness of
labels how we might try to implement
this kind of constraints in different
um centrality metrics
for example if I'm looking at the degree
distribution I can think about doing uh
I I can impose statistical parity in the
campaign in a way that's like strict so
I want to ensure that the proportion of
people in their early adopters among the
two communities is almost the same or
exactly the same as the general
population so it's a strict condition
or I can do the same thing but then a
relaxed version where I allow some
Epsilon wiggle room that actually in
practice helps so much with getting more
people in the Outreach and I want to
compare how this strategic seating in
which I'm trying to impose this kind of
constraints will compare with the
Baseline in which I don't know any
Community Information I only know the
network and I'm sitting based on my
usual
um centrality metric for example degree
there's a question in the back you know
since you know knowledge of the network
why
um why I post a statistical parity on
the seating as opposed to
estimate the Outreach emergency
yeah yeah
I'll repeat the question so if we know
the information about the network why
impose the constrained and the level of
the early adopters instead of the
Outreach so earlier there's the the
other paper that's related to this which
is uh this one is showing that if you're
doing positions straight at the level of
the Outreach in most cases or not you're
going to get this trade-off and the
trade-off looks quite big and it looks
like if you do that our intuition was
that you're not actually being efficient
in the seating when you're imposing this
constraint in the Outreach but if if you
do can impose this constraint at the
level of the early adopter set then
you're able to actually improve the
seating
um in a way that's leveraging Network
information in a better way this one
doesn't really leverage Network
information that
um that much in a way or or it is but
only at the level of the Outreach so
I think it's interesting I don't know if
there's a particular
proof or something rigorous that we can
see with that but that's a big
difference you get a trade-off here you
don't there are many cases in which you
don't get a trade-off where you impose
this constraint earlier
and and the rest of the talk I'm gonna
show you how imposing that constraint
earlier is going to help out a lot
other questions at this point
yes to come back to a question so I
guess the idea is that you're not fair
because you select
um
doesn't have the same degree for
instance so the distribution of the
degrees is different
so if you yeah the parity on the seeding
how did you come back to Europe
I don't guarantee parity in the outcome
because eventually yeah the Assumption
was that there was you know yes the
shift in distribution right yes yes so
we're going to see that that's basically
uh let me repeat that question to I
think for example to here also
um the question was if you impose a
constraints on the on at the level of
the early adopter set how do you
guarantee parity in the Outreach as well
and you can guarantee it in very
particular conditions so depending on
how the network actually looks like you
can get 19 and depending on the network
structure you may be able to impose
different slightly different constraints
other adopters in order to get anything
parity in the Outreach
um and I'm going to talk about that in
an in the network model to show you like
when you can guarantee and what could
basically you probably cannot
okay but these are good questions so and
let me show you how this would look like
as an example of what does it mean to
impose this kind of constraints on a
centrality metric for example let's say
we're looking at degree degrees
sometimes as well sometimes it doesn't
really do that well but in in a lot of
the experimental data it's something to
start with
if you are choosing a seed set based
just on degree and you have a particular
budget you're just gonna look at that
budget and chose people above a certain
threshold no matter what community there
are this is just them Rank by degree and
that's your early adopters set
if you want to be fair in your early
adopter set if you want to be strictly
fair you're going to say well how many
people who are red and who are blue do I
have in my general population and how do
I get them to be in that early adopter
set so I have to choose in this case as
Claire said maybe you have different
degree distributions which is one
mechanism through which the uh degree
centrality will be biased or will be
unequal among the two communities and in
that case you'd say well I do need more
of the people who are red I do need to
lower my degree threshold for them and
include those with a bit lower degree
but I do have the budget so I need to
choose fewer of the blue people before
so that means I chose people who are in
the minority or by this case no minority
but who have lower degree and I added
them to the seed set
um and I want to know what happens now
with the Outreach
and I can do that in a way that's strict
or I can do that in a way that's in a
relaxed version in which maybe I don't
need full statistical parity maybe I can
have some wiggle room up to some Epsilon
okay so the the I want to show you like
this kind of
um strategies work in with particular
depending on the assumptions that you
have with the network model itself and
one of the the reasons we're using that
is not to say like this is the right
strategy necessarily to use this is just
one methodology that depending on the
network structure you can differ your
strategies on how you choose people in
the seat set depending on what you can
estimate from the network itself
and the network model that we're using
is basically serving the purpose of
trying to explain where did bias come
from we know there's some bias in the
Outreach that's something experimental
data has shown in the past we also
noticed that but we want to know like
what's a mechanism that would tell me
this is why degree centrality is biased
or this is one way in which some
centrality metrics are biased
so it in a sense it explains one model
of a degree difference or the
distribution and decrease difference in
the between the two communities and how
that may propagate within the seating
algorithms that we have and it's useful
to prove our guarantees about what we
want to know
and basically it tells us it's one
mechanism to tell us like where and how
we should intervene based on that model
with this strategies to improve seating
so let me tell you how the bottom model
looks like and based on a Model you're
going to see that well it will be quite
intuitive why the some assumptions in
this model make it easy to be more fair
but it only depends necessarily on the
model it's just that depending on what
assumptions you make you may be able to
create strategies that are more fair
so the model that we're using is a
variant of the preferential attachment
model in which you also have two
communities
so you have you have two groups someone
comes into the network they choose a
label blue or red and let's say these
two groups are different in numbers so
let's say the fraction of the red notes
is smaller than half they're in the
minority
at each time step new people come in
they choose the their label and they
create a number of connections
um by connecting with probability
proportional to the existing notes
degree
once they do that though there's a third
um element to it which is homophily
that's an assumption in this model
meaning that if you have different
labels you're going to connect only with
the probability row and if you're the
same label you always connect so if you
don't connect sometimes you may rewire
and this model was proposed a few years
ago it's really interesting because it
has this skew degree distribution that
sometimes it's interesting to look at
um and it has this community effect and
it's really easy to to really useful to
analyze in in terms of centrality
metrics
so let me show you an example of how
this model looks like you have a
snapshot of the of the network at a
particular time with connections and
nodes
um
and you know it comes in it uses a color
blue or red you can say it's blue and it
connects with a preferential attachment
let's say it chooses this node it's a
different color so because we're in we
have this rewiring probability that is
motivated by homophily it would say it
will accept or reject
um the connection if it accepts it will
accept it with the the probability of
homophily row if it rejects it just
redoes this process until it gets an
edge and you can do that by everyone
creating a number of edges with the
existing
um Network and this model grows
asymptotically so the purpose is to
analyze what happens with seeding
strategies giving this model
asymptotically as well
the model is interesting in in the sense
that it shows there's an uh inequality
in the degree distribution between the
two communities
and having General showed that well the
the we know that preference attachment
follows the power law this model in the
two communities also follow power law
each of them with a different
coefficient
the fact that this coefficient is
different is one way to think that um
that that's one case in which you're
going to see degree centrality to be
biased of course because the proportion
of nodes in minority is going to be over
a certain degree or it's going to be
basically Vanishing as the degree
increases because of this power law
difference in the coefficients
so if you're back to our seating
strategies and trying to compare them
this is one way in which we see what
we've seen in the data basically that a
lot of the centrality metrics including
the degree what I'm showing here shows
that one of the group is really really
under represented they have much lower
degree than everyone else
so the purpose is to compare these
strategies and to figure out like what
when they can do better both in terms of
fairness but also in terms of Outreach
and the first result which is
um intuitive given the assumptions of
the model is that well both diversity
sitting and parity sitting can lead to a
fair Outreach for the same budget
so they can improve the proportion of
the minority that's um being represented
in the Outreach uh given that we have
the same constraints why because well
the network is homophilic so if you add
more nodes even if they have lower
degree on in the in the seats that are
just going to reach more of that
community that they're a part of that
wouldn't work of course if the model is
not homophilic and depending on that you
may want to change the strategy and how
what kind of thresholds you may choose
for this or who you are you actually
including in the seed set selection
but in this particular case in which
we're assuming homophilia and this kind
of strategies this is what you get the
second result that's less intuitive than
the first is that there is a particular
point there are a set of conditions in
which both diversity suiting and parody
seating can outperform agnostic seating
in the Outreach they do do better
and that point depends on the size of
the seat set how big your budget is
for a very small budget but I'm going to
show you how that looks like maybe you
get a trade-off and practice the trade
it was actually really small and at some
point as the seaside increases you're
able to be more fair and more efficient
at the same time
it's safe
yes sorry this is a typo
should be the constraint is that the
seed sets are the same size for all
three
um for all three seedling mechanisms
yeah thank you she wants to make sure
you're pregnant
that was the test
okay anyway it's true what you write
there as well
and any duration of the proof is that
well the goal is to basically figure out
whether there are these thresholds
basically these different thresholds
that we can choose in order to get a
better Outreach or to be able to
estimate an Outreach that's better in
Paradigm City and diversity seating then
we would have with agnostic seating and
it's it's
um not necessarily easy but but it is
one way because of this model it is nice
to be able to compute it in a couple of
steps first of all by estimating the
first step influence size of a
particular seat set and then extend that
to an estimation by multiple steps of
the size of the Cascade given a
particular seed set for a particular
threshold given that you have a budget
that you may care about here
um here you know should be a budget you
can compute what's the degree threshold
that you need in order to get that many
people in in the seed set size that you
have so if I have K people in my seats
at size I and I'm choosing them by
degree I know how many people I need uh
what's the degrees threshold above which
I can choose because I know the degree
distribution of this network and I know
it for both groups but because of that I
can compute it in general
I'm not going to talk about the Second
Step which is a an estimation step but a
quick point about the first step in
doing so is that we do know the science
as I mentioned before we know the degree
distribution if I was a parallel with
coefficient with different coefficients
so we can estimate a variety of things
including how what would be
um the the
um uh the degree threshold above which
we need to choose notes in order to be
within our constraint and we can compute
the first order influenced by Computing
basically the probability of a node
being influenced by one Edge whether
it's a blue and red and combining these
two to have our estimation
once we do that we we which we basically
all of this rely on on the network
process
um formation because I can write this in
terms of like what's the probability of
an edge to have been formed versus the
the the uh fraction of edges that have
been formed among different communities
and I can estimate this
once we do that we want to go back to
thinking about like well can I have
these two thresholds that give me an
expectation a better
um Outreach if I have different
thresholds or not
and one way to do that is is a mechanism
in which I just think well I can just
transform this into a function of
figuring out at which point in this
different thresholds
um do I have to be in order to get a
better Outreach and writing that as a
function of that point in X in a
continuous form I can just study the
anal analyze the behavior of that
function and just basically figure out
that that point exists and you can
compute it in closed form and find a
particular threshold above which the
seat set size is large enough so I can
be more fair and more efficient at the
same time
so I want to show you how that looks
like so the way that would look like in
theory and I'm going to show you why how
that matches to the data soon as well
this is a uh basically theoretical
simulations from a network generated
from this preferential attachment with
two communities and the parameters fit
more or less the data that we have used
as well so if you have we have about 53
000 nodes to communities some homophilic
parameter and on the x axis is the size
of the minority so at 0.10 you have 10
minority in red 90 percent majority in
blue As you move towards the right you
get to more and more equal
subpopulations where you get the
variance 0.45 means 45 percent are
minority in red 55 majority input
the y-axis is the seat set size the size
of our campaign and here we're looking
at pretty large
um campaigns I'm going to show you a few
experimentary results on smaller
campaigns as well so
the different colors represent on which
heuristic did better in Outreach
compared to the agnostic so if you look
at the orange region this is the region
of parameters in which being agnostic
will get you better Outreach than being
diverse or be for diversity seating or
parity sitting it's basically telling
you you're going to get some trade-off
between being fair and being efficient
and that trade-off is not really large
particularly in practice but it's there
As you move up on the y-axis at some
point you reach a size of the campaign
in which you're transitioning into this
blue region and this blue region tells
you that you're going to do better in
Outreach with diversity sitting than
agnostic and as a side note well
diversity sitting is a relaxed version
of parity sitting so it's always doing
better than the strict conditional
statistical parity in Outreach
and what you notice here is that
um as communities become more and more
equal so we're moving right on the
x-axis you get this bound blue boundary
line that's monotonically decreasing
meaning that you need fewer and fewer
seeds in order to be both fair and
efficient at the same time
and in a sense with this relaxed version
that makes sense because the communities
are more equal you're not when you're
choosing nodes with lower degree you're
not actually like losing so much in your
influence potential
but a different effect happens when
we're moving up on the seat set size
parameter and we enter in this purple
region in which actually when you have
enough seeds the the strict parity
condition parody seating also performs
better than agnostic in the Outreach
that's where being strictly Fair also
gets you to be more efficient in the
Outreach as well
and what you notice here is that well as
the network becomes more equal
among the two communities at some point
it becomes really much much harder to be
more fair and more efficient at the same
time you need much much more seeds than
you had needed before
so it's no longer a linear effect which
at the first glance it's a bit
um contradicting or or not expected but
when you think about it basically when
when you have a small minority if you're
trying to be strictly fair you would say
I want a node from my minority group and
that node is going to have much lower
degree but that's okay because it
reaches a community that I have not
influenced before I would have not
chosen that node in my agnostic seating
and uh now I'm I reach in a new
community community
but when the network becomes much more
more equal these minority nodes don't
have such a lower such a low degree
they're already pretty high degree
they've already been influenced the
community that the minority Community
it's not a new community I'm trying to
tap into they're kind of influence but
it's really really much harder to get
them to be influenced in a fair way
um so
in in a sense that's why I need to spend
way more budget to use this lower degree
nodes in order to be strictly Fair
whereas in the other case when I'm
choosing notes that are very Central
that come from a majority group I'm
actually being inefficient because I'm
choosing those that have this
overlapping sphere of influence more or
less although they have high centrality
they're not really getting me to new
parts of the network
so and I have a question so
so you say this is a theoretical
analysis but it's a
it's a simulation right so can you
actually do this also analytically or
not because preferential attachment I
mean calculation so you eventually have
to do percolation on preferential
attachment and now you have to do
preference calculation and preferential
attachment resistor types and stuff yeah
that sounds pretty scary to me it is it
is but what you can do though is that
the this previous result is telling us
where is it here you can do some
estimation of
the influence
perhaps for a few steps and then from
then on assume that uh that's as much as
you can go in this estimation with a
preferential attachment and it's
basically telling you that we can find
these close form threshold such that we
know when we can get be more fair and
more efficient at the same time we know
we're always going to be more fair
that's something that's easier to prove
but it's harder to prove when we're
going to be more efficient too but
basically this is telling you that yes I
can actually know the the form of this
parameter so that any particular
parameter I know where this threshold is
the theory tells me like what a
threshold is in theory and then I take
that and I compute it and I plot it here
so this is
um this is not simulated from when is
the Outreach actually better in
simulating influence this is simulated
from the theory result that is telling
us where this boundary line is
does that
was that a question yeah well no I don't
so is this curve so this is a numerical
so is it simulated like Monte Carlo is
it the numerical solution of some it's a
numerical solution of some migration
with some differential equations of some
equations that we saw before yeah okay
thanks yeah
do you have a question also exactly yes
a question there
uh can you say something about how much
one strategy outperforms another in
these different regions yeah so so in
theory we can't really estimate by how
much like these three results are kind
of limited to showing it will outperform
by how much or abound on that we don't
have that's an interesting thing I hope
someone works on that yeah and
simulations in simulations you can
definitely do it so I'll show you how
how what happens in simulations that
we're simulating the Cascade but on Real
uh network data
so let me show you how bad or good this
gets given that
um we have a real network data that's
collected from dblp this network of
computer scientists uh science papers
where there's a citation Network and
there's two groups men and women and the
women are in minority in this case
they're about 90 percent of the
population so we're about at this
vertical line here
so what we do here is you can simulate
the diffusion process
um average it over many times and Report
what happens at different level of the
seed sets
yes so this basically this simulation
here is basically it is based on an
estimated homophily parameter from the
data set itself which tells me that
there are two homophilic groups
um and these two groups yeah they're
quite clustered together basically
um and it's something similar we saw
with a bunch of other data sets in which
monthly was available as well but I'm
only showing one
okay so let me show you what happens
let's say you have like a you know
relatively small seed set size not that
small but you have a thousand seats
given the network size
um we're basically the theory tells us
we're in this region or where agnostic
City should do better than everyone else
and it does so not by much this is
averaged over about 10 000 simulations
so what you see in the first row is that
both parity sitting in diversity sitting
they lose some Outreach but they lose so
little Outreach whereas they do improve
the the fraction of women in the
Outreach as well
if you do increase the number of seeds
what happens is that in theory let's say
we're looking at 5000 seeds Theory
becomes a little bit more conservative
than the what the real data actually
shows in the sense that we're expecting
to still be in this agnostic does the
best
um case in this orange region but in
practice at 5000 C's we actually moved
in the blue region where diversity
seating actually starts to outperform
agnostic sitting in the Outreach itself
and this is for one probability of
diffusion 0.01
it doesn't outperform by much again the
difference is pretty small but when you
think that you remove some high degree
nodes and you you got some lower degree
notes from the minority group and they
were able to overcome that difference
and influence overall more people that's
where you see this difference looks
um uh more exciting
question
someone
already Yes
um in this case we work with
uh let me remember I believe it was
unoriented
I remember correct but I would check
your
resurrections
okay now since we have all the model can
be done for both oriented or unoriented
we get a similar result of the degree
but I think
I'll check that I don't want to see
something wrong
um
so well for yeah so that one happens for
five thousand seats let's say you're
increasing the number of seeds and at
some point that they were looking at a
bit about nine thousand seats
um and you're expecting again the Theory
actually shows to be a little bit more
conservative of why the simulation shows
because in reality what we see is that
both parody and Camp diversity actually
get to get get you more people in the
Outreach overall on average so in
practice we're actually in this purple
region that the theory suggested
so here you may you you uh what's nice
to see is that well depending on how big
your seat set size is you may want to do
different things you may have a
trade-off between how many people you're
reaching and uh um how was the fraction
of different communities in the Outreach
as well both with this data set and with
other data sets we looked at the
difference is the trade-offs are really
really not that high the nice part about
showing
um or having demonstrated the level of
the early adopters is that it allows us
through the network model to estimate
the Cascade and to get us this
map that more or less in a conservative
way matches what we see in practice too
so it would tell you like that it is
worth doing or trying to explore the
network a little bit more and of course
the methods that you may use are like
the exact searches you may use may
depend on the network model uh choices
that you may have because this is all
based on having of course you have a
homophilic network and you add more
people from one of the group in the seed
set of course you're going to get more
of those in the Outreach as well that
may differ if the network looks
different as well
there are different extensions that we
were thinking about including like you
know what happens for different uh
mechanisms
um seating mechanism instead of like
degree
so for example if we're looking
uh Let's ignore the ethics well I'll
talk about that extension but if you
look at degree discount a very similar
effect happens if you're looking at
fewer seeds so like if you're looking at
very small seating up to like I don't
know if you can see the numbers here as
I see
um anyway up to 30 seeds
the plots here just show you the
Outreach between the different seating
mechanisms let's say you have agnostic
or diversity and so on they're pretty
similar the trade-off is really really
invisible almost over many simulations
you can do more than that and think
about well I can be fair at the level of
my seatside selection I can prefer the
level of the Outreach is it worth
thinking about interventions in between
do I does more Network information or or
an intermediate Network information
level actually helps me and it does help
me like for example if I think about
extending the statistical priority
condition from the seed set to the
neighbors of the seeds and thinking
about what's the the community
affiliation of those call that neighbor
seating that actually helps quite a bit
it helps in the degree and again maybe
the the other screens are better for
these pictures but what I'm trying to
show is that the Outreach is very very
similar between agnostic seating
diversity sitting and neighbor seating
and actually you do get a higher
fraction of the minority in the Outreach
for neighbor sitting than you would even
for diversity seating itself there's no
theory that we're proving for that this
is just experimental results
and if you do increase the number of
seats to say a thousand you you a
neighbor seating does actually pretty
well in practice too
so
depending of course I'm like how well
the the centrality metric does as well
you may think about well what happened
what happens with green maybe degree is
just like a terrible thing to do if you
actually might want to do greetings then
and you have enough Network information
well if you do look at greedy I'm just
showing here for for a thousand since
but a similar effect happens for for
larger amount of cities that The
trade-offs are really small maybe
neighbor sitting doesn't do as well but
diversity seating actually does really
really well for a variety of seeds
here's just zero to Thirty seeds a very
small seedset selection where
the outreach are very very similar
indistinguishable if you do increase the
number of seeds a thousand or even above
you actually do better in diversity
seating
here's a question
sorry
so the greedy algorithm is the same
algorithm from campaign climb retardosh
where you like you do it iteratively you
do you don't know you get the first now
with the best
um influence maximization over many
rounds and then you choose that one and
you get the next one that gets you the
best marginal increase in influence than
what you already got so it's trying to
use this subodular property of the
independent Cascade to get you to a good
algorithm it's much harder to analyze
greedy theoretically so that's why we
looked at mostly network centrality uh
measures for which you you have just
partial Network information with video
with assume you have the entire network
information
um and a bunch of very similar results
happen for a variety of other metrics
um in in in practice from like degree
discount which is a version of the
greeting which you're trying to Discount
where nodes of high degree have similar
spheres of influence and to like remove
that or for between a centrality and so
on and even for for random but at that
point random is just a very
characteristic and if you want to use
random you should just be random and
that's probably Fair
um anyway
so there's a bunch of directions from
here and a bunch of open questions some
of them that we have mentioned before
what happens with other models Beyond
independent Cascade
um a related work was
um it's gonna show uh with studying
fairness in the linear threshold model
becomes much harder to prove as people
have previously mentioned that as well
what happens for other centrality
metrics more than the Practical
Solutions we see that's another question
what happens for different kind of
models our model is pretty specific it
it looks like how the data looks like of
course but you may be interested in
other modeling choices depending on what
data you have
um another question such as you know how
does the network formation
um process take place with relationship
to who influences who there are recent
works that are trying that are working
on this from
um uh for example this paper on causal
estimation of peer influences social
networks am I friends with people
because we influenced each other or did
I influence them because we were friends
to begin with
um so that may inspire a different kind
of modeling questions
um to to study
I think I'll stop here and let's see if
there are any other questions from
everyone
[Music]
you said there was a
um
is it all
right
okay yeah
so uh there was a difference between
Theory result and the experiments here
did you try to like uh change the
homophilia like to see if qualitatively
like these curves look the same like
these convex and the concave yeah no we
do we did so so they do look similar in
uh shape when you change homophily there
just depends like the threshold actually
changes because it is an input to the uh
parameter that to the threshold that
tells you how many seeds you need the
the remotely parameter we use here we
try to estimate it from like how the
data looks like but maybe there might be
a question like maybe that's not the
right estimation or maybe they're better
estimations for which we can get
slightly different uh figure of where
exactly we are in this space but the
behavior is the same
yeah and what why do you think is the
main reason that you see it our
intuition was that well on the one hand
if you have people who are very Central
sorry if you have a very a small
minority and you're in this region you
would expect that
um basically the people who have very
high degree have this overlapping sphere
of influence I have a small minority if
I'm choosing someone with small degree
I'm actually getting to a new part of
the network so I'm gaining a lot so like
as a network is like relatively as the
minority is relatively small I'm kind of
following the same Trend as diversity
sitting but at some point the minority
group is large enough that in the degree
selection or in in the degree centrality
they're still kind of represented
they're not completely out of the loop
they've been influenced to some extent
but it's much harder to influence them
to the actual proportion that they they
they have in the network and there's
this um interesting basically
competition that happens when when nodes
of minority Community come into the
network and you have homophilia they
kind of try to decide like well am I
gonna connect with a majority node
um
that has a higher degree but it's a
different color or with the minority
node that's the same color as me but
lower degree which creates this
community effect and when you have that
and you still have a relatively large
minority Community it's like they have
lower degree but they're still kind of
influenced so it's really hard to
overcome that and you need much higher
seeds to seeds that to overcome that
that's our intuition from it but yeah
a little bit tangential but like it
seems like at least in the simulations
the
the the fairness of the agnostic ceiling
seems to be not that bad right yeah
depending on how many seats you get it
can be terrible or it's not that yeah so
is it monotonically like I wanted to
know whether if more seeds are making my
fairness better like in the senses can I
say something like I only need a few
more seeds to become Fair like even if I
do like uh agnostic seating
um can I get something like that Crystal
like oh I see what you mean like I don't
know anything about the network
structure all I want to say is that
instead of using thousand if I can use
like 2 000 okay that's a big jump but
like if I can use two thousand can I get
a much fairer am I getting close to
being more fair or is it like very wacky
like that there is no not really it
doesn't really change with the seat set
size I'm only showing like three
iterations of citizer size and this is
for this data set it doesn't do terribly
so I have 19 of women in the in in the
almost 90 in data set maybe this is like
16 so I lost two percent maybe it's not
that terrible another data says the loss
is like much higher but even in this
data set where the loss is not that bad
and and those as well I can go as low or
as high and I'm not actually like
improving it's the same it's going to
stay the same at whatever seats or size
I have it's in practice it doesn't help
that much thank you I mean maybe
sometimes it helps and given yeah
um
yeah maybe it would help if instead of
agnostics dealing with that set as the
previous results show you would do
random suiting and random seating you do
get a similar Outreach but you're
expected to be much fairer
thank you
another question yeah
hi
um so I have more of a general like uh
kind of intuition question I guess I was
wondering so here you have a constant
homophily parameter right if you were
assuming kind of say you have two
classes of homophily parameter where one
is you know one one's minority group is
much more likely to connect with their
you can come off listen another one is
much more likely to connect to you I
wonder if like I guess intuitively I
might think this diversity outperforming
purple regions will kind of shrink as
you have larger gaps in yeah like what's
your I think your intuition is right oh
we didn't do that analysis we did do
this analysis for this model with a
different application in which you can
set different homophobically parameters
and basically you can compute everything
in the same same way so it doesn't
really add much uh complexity just but
but you're able to see differences one
thing that you do notice is that that we
did notice is that when you do have
um a minority that has a higher
homophilic parameter than the majority
actually at some point
um the degree distribution gets to be
the same so a more homophilic minority
is able to actually get you the same a
coefficient in the degree distribution
then uh as as the majority in some
conditions depending on like how
close together like what the homophilic
parameters actually are and on the size
of the minority you have like one
percent minority no matter how
homophilic they are they'll never be
able to equalize this but if they're in
in some ranges that you you can actually
prove for this model you can show that
these actually like become equal and
when those become equal maybe it's not
such a big issue to think about seeding
or how to make seeding Fair because it's
already kind of fair because there are
proportions in high uh in centrality
metrics are the same among the two
groups but I think that's a really good
question
so quick quick follow-up do you in when
you when you're looking at this dblp
data do you actually notice that a
constant homophily is a better estimate
of the data or is it more is there a
distribution there
um good question for that it's not that
it wasn't that different from what I
remember in the data and other data sets
becomes really different and it creates
interesting effect this one is more or
less the same definitely I think the
minority in this case the women were a
little bit more homophilic but not by
much but I I I can look up the table for
that later yeah
and that is a type of proof that you
have here so you can do you know you
look at a branching process starting
from a random node then you can
follow based on the homophilic measure
how many vertices you see from each time
that's the part that Christian was
saying it's like becomes complicated
you can kind of do it but it comes
really complicated after that
you might have approximated and then it
is not a very key result approximated
view beyond that so that's as much as
this gives us I see I was under the
impression that your branching process
you have to worry about only the first
step after that as long as it's three
like
so yourself it changes the wrong
generation oh
oh no whether it actually changes after
a couple of steps like it becomes
in a different analysis we're looking at
like random walks of times two on this
um in this graph and looking at how
random what what's the next compared to
your immediate number but they're not
that different so I don't expect that it
actually changes that much between one
step two steps it's kind of the same
three steps it becomes kind of hard to
know how similar it is because the
patients get really complicated but
um beyond that okay maybe first foreign